Été 1945...
la fête de la Victoire sur
la place Rouge à Moscou.
Devant les dirigeants soviétiques,
l'armée russe célèbre
la victoire sur l'Allemagne nazie.
Comme sous l'empire romain,
les soldats jettent les drapeaux
des vaincus au pied du vainqueur.
L'homme qui a battu Hitler,
Joseph Staline.
Après 20 ans
de pouvoir personnel,
le maître de l'URSS est
au sommet de sa gloire.
Un poète écrit,
- « Staline,
tu es plus haut que
les hauts espaces célestes
et seules tes pensées
sont plus hautes que toi.
Ton esprit Staline
est plus lumineux que le soleil. »
- On l'appelle
le petit père des peuples.
Dans le monde entier, il incarne
l'espoir d'une société plus juste.
Il est l'idole de centaines
de millions de personnes.
En France aussi
on chante ces louanges.
- Oui, de tout notre cœur,
nous proclamons notre
amour ardent pour Staline
et nous l'assurons
de notre confiance inébranlable.
- Pourtant cet homme est l'un
des plus grands criminels de l'histoire.
Il a massacré son propre peuple.
- « Nous anéantirons sans pitié
quiconque menace par les faits
ou même par la pensée,
l'unité de l'État. »
- Il a réduit en esclavage
18 millions de personnes.
- «Il faut trancher les membres nuisibles
du parti pour le préserver de la maladie
et de l'infection. »
- Il a provoqué avec cynisme des famines
qui ont fait des millions de victimes.
- « La mort résout tous les problèmes.
Plus d'hommes, plus de problèmes. »
- Il a sacrifié sa famille
à son propre pouvoir.
- « Un vrai bolchevique
ne devrait pas avoir de famille. »
- Voici l'histoire incroyable
de ce fils d'un petit artisan devenu
l'un des personnages
les plus puissants de la planète.
L'histoire de l'homme qui déclarait
faire le bonheur de son peuple
et qui est devenu à force
de mégalomanie et de fanatisme
l'un des dictateurs les plus
sanglants que l'humanité ait connu.
L'année 1924.
Les environs de Moscou,
en plein hiver russe.
Lénine, le père de la révolution
bolchevique, vient de mourir.
C'est l'un des premiers
films où apparaissait Staline.
Avec les responsables soviétiques,
il porte le cercueil du chef.
Staline a 46 ans.
Il est secrétaire général
du parti communiste,
un poste relativement effacé.
Parmi ses camarades,
personne n'imagine encore que
c'est lui qui va succéder au grand Lénine.
Ils n'imaginent pas que dans dix ans,
il les aura presque tous fait liquider.
Parmi eux,
personne n'a encore compris
qui est vraiment Joseph Staline.
Pour ses camarades,
c'est un personnage insignifiant.
- « Staline est la plus éminente
médiocrité de notre parti.
Nous ne craignons pas Staline.
Aussitôt qu'il voudra prendre
de grands airs, nous l'éliminerons. »
- Depuis toujours,
Staline cache son jeu.
Son vrai nom est Iossif Djougachvili.
Il est né en 1878,
au temps des tsars.
Un régime monarchique
fondé sur l'inégalité
et la soumission aux souverains.
Une enfance dans la misère.
Un père alcoolique et violent.
Éduqué par les moines orthodoxes,
il a basculé très tôt
dans la lutte contre le tsar
et il a pris le nom de Staline,
l'homme d'acier.
En 1917, il a participé avec Lénine
à la grande révolution bolchevique.
Une révolution qui a renversé le tsar,
aboli les privilèges
et donner le pouvoir au peuple.
Dans l'ombre de Lénine,
il attend une occasion
pour prendre le pouvoir.
La mort de Lénine est cette occasion.
En 1924, il réussit
par des manœuvres politiques
à écarter le plus haut
personnage du moment,
Léon Trotski,
avant de l'exiler.
Staline en quelques mois
s'empare du pouvoir.
Il ne le quittera plus.
Il choisit de s'installer ici,
dans la citadelle du Kremlin,
l'ancien palais des tsars.
C'est d'ici qu'il va diriger l'URSS.
L'Union des Républiques
Socialistes Soviétiques,
le plus grand pays de la planète.
Avec quelques fidèles qui vont
le suivre pendant près de 30 ans,
il veut aller plus loin que Lénine.
Il veut changer le cours de l'histoire.
- « Nous les bolcheviques,
nous sommes d'une race spéciale.
L'élément personnel ne vaut pas un clou.
N'en doutez pas, camarades.
Je suis prêt
à consacrer à la classe ouvrière
toute ma force
et chaque goutte de mon sang. »
- Staline veut faire
table race du passé.
Il supprime brutalement
les traces de la vieille Russie
que la révolution avait épargnée.
Il décrète la religion
contraire aux intérêts du peuple.
Dans tout le pays,
il fait disparaître
les symboles de l'ancien régime.
À la place,
il nourrit un projet radical,
le communisme.
Une société idéale.
Sans riche ni pauvre.
Un monde où
tout est mis en commun.
Un monde où chacun
a les mêmes chances à la naissance.
Un monde où la santé et
l'éducation sont accessibles à tous.
Pour l'Union Soviétique,
il éprouve une ambition sans bornes.
- « La vieille Russie a toujours
été battue à cause de son retard.
Ralentir le rythme
signifie être à la traîne
et les traînards seront battus.
Nous, en Union Soviétique,
nous ne voulons plus être battus. »
- Il lance de gigantesques chantiers,
gratte-ciel,
métro,
chemin de fer,
barrage.
Il veut moderniser la Russie
à marche forcée
pour qu'elle devienne
le paradis des travailleurs.
Un monde où le chômage n'existe pas.
et où chaque ouvrier peut offrir
une existence décente à sa famille.
- Nous,
les pionniers de la grande patrie,
les soldats du parti, toujours prêts.
Nous te remercions Staline
pour le bonheur que
tu procures à notre pays.
- Staline est le guide
éclairé des communistes.
Son portrait est partout.
Chaque Soviétique doit
le vénérer en toutes circonstances.
Il doit être parfait, car il représente
la réussite du communisme.
Il a lui-même corrigé
sa biographie officielle, vendue
à des millions d'exemplaires.
Sur les épreuves,
il a noté à la main...
- « Ajoutez la phrase,
Staline est le plus grand
capitaine de tous les temps
et de tous les peuples. »
- Le vrai Staline n'est plus banal.
Il mesure 1m60.
Il porte des chaussures
à semelles compensées.
Souvent, il se tient sur une petite plaque
de bois qui le grandit encore un peu.
Regardez cette image,
c'est son vrai visage.
Sa peau est grêlée, car il a attrapé
la variole à l'âge de sept ans.
Curieusement,
en public,
il n'en paraît rien.
Le nouveau maître du Kremlin
est un mystère pour ces sujets.
Il vit enfermé dans son bureau
et il cache jalousement sa vie privée.
Voici les photos qui nous
sont restées de sa femme Nadia,
une ancienne camarade de lutte
de 22 ans sa cadette.
Avec elle, il a eu deux enfants.
Vassili et Svetlana,
sa fille chérie.
Il exerce sur elle
une véritable fascination.
- « Du moment que papa m'aime, ça m'est
égal que le monde entier me déteste.
Si papa me demandait
d'aller dans la lune,
je le ferai. »
- De très rares clichés nous montrent
Staline dans ces moments de détente
pendant les vacances d'été
quand il emmène
ses adjoints sur la mer Noire.
Ekaterina Vorochilov,
la femme d'un de ses
lieutenants se souvient.
- « Staline aimait
les expéditions dans la nature.
Il nous emmenait en voiture
et on s'installait
à côté d'une rivière.
On allumait un feu,
on faisait griller de la viande
en plaisantant et en chantant.
C'était vraiment le bon temps. »
- Pourtant, dès les premières années,
les mauvaises nouvelles s'accumulent.
La politique de Staline
pose problème.
Le niveau de vie
commence à se détériorer.
En multipliant
les projets industriels,
Staline a sacrifié
la vie quotidienne.
La population augmente,
mais la construction
de logements ne suit pas.
Des familles entières s'entassent
dans de tout petits espaces.
Regardez ces images,
elles ont été tournées quasi
clandestinement dans les rues de Moscou.
Elle constitue un des rares
témoignages de la pauvreté
au début des années 30.
C'est cette riche anglaise,
Lady Mountbatten qui au cours d'un
voyage a filmé avec sa caméra personnelle.
- « Je vois partout
des signes de malnutrition.
Ce vieil homme qui fouille dans
les poubelles est un ancien aristocrate.
Il était un professeur
réputé à l'époque des tsars
Voici un petit garçon qui est tout seul
et qui me demande de l'aide.
Les vitrines des magasins
sont presque vides.
Surtout, les files d'attente
sont interminables.
Dans la queue, certains restent
toute la journée à attendre,
sans rien pouvoir acheter. »
- En URSS,
le rêve communiste est déjà
en train de se fissurer.
Au Kremlin,
Staline ne veut rien entendre.
Pour lui, l'échec n'existe pas.
Si le système est défaillant
c'est qu'on sabote sa politique.
Il cherche des coupables
chez les responsables de l'économie.
Comme le commissaire
aux finances, Brioukhanov
qu'il juge incompétent
et qu'un collaborateur
a dessiné en fâcheuse posture.
En marge du dessin,
Staline écrit.
- « Pour tous ces péchés
passés et présents,
pendez Brioukhanov par les testicules.
Si elles tiennent,
considérez-le comme
acquitté par le tribunal.
Si elles lâchent,
jetez-le dans la rivière. »
- Staline ne plaisante qu'à moitié.
En 1930, il invente une méthode pour
désigner officiellement les coupables.
Le procès politique.
Les accusés sont des scientifiques,
des ingénieurs,
des hauts fonctionnaires.
Ils sont tous compétents,
mais Staline les accuse d'avoir
saboté l'économie soviétique.
- Levez-vous !
- Staline lui-même est absent
des débats, mais il a nommé comme juge
l'un de ses fidèles.
Andreï Vychinski.
Il lui a fixé les peines à prononcer.
La mort.
- J'annonce ouverte,
la séance du tribunal spécial,
du gouvernement de l'union
des Républiques Socialistes Soviétiques.
- Pour que le procès paraisse
crédible aux yeux de tous,
il faut que les accusés
avouent leur faute.
Ils ont été torturés
pendant des semaines
et ils n'ont pas vraiment le choix.
- Comment vous dire...
Je vous ai déjà expliqué
dans ma dernière déclaration
que mes sentiments
contre-révolutionnaires
à l'égard du pouvoir soviétique
que ces sentiments
ne m'ont jamais vraiment quitté.
- Je reconnais tout à fait que...
que je mérite le pire des châtiments.
- Pour le procureur,
c'est alors un jeune enfant.
- Le gouvernement vous reconnait coupables
et demande que
les accusés soient fusillés.
- Après plusieurs jours de gesticulation,
le juge prononce le verdict.
Non sans une certaine émotion.
- Kalininkov Ivan Andreievich
selon les articles 583, 584,
586 et 581 du code de L'URSS
l'Union Soviétique
vous condamne à la plus haute peine.
- Leur peine sera commuée en dix ans
de prison, mais le message est clair.
Ceux qui s'opposent
à Staline seront écrasés.
Avec ses proches aussi,
Staline devient brutal.
Ses relations avec son fils aîné Iakov,
né d'un premier mariage, son glacial.
Il a récemment fait
une tentative de suicide,
son père n'a montré
aucune compassion.
- « Dire qu'il n'a
même pas pu viser juste.
Je ne peux rien avoir
en commun avec lui. »
- Le couple de Staline
lui aussi va mal.
Sa femme Nadia est fragile.
Elle souffre d'être rabrouée
en permanence par son mari.
Au cours d'une dispute
où Staline l'a insulté,
elle s'en porte.
- « Tu es un bourreau.
Voilà ce que tu es.
Tu tourmentes ton propre fils,
ta femme,
le peuple russe.
Il est impossible de vivre avec toi. »
- Après 14 ans de vie commune,
Nadia est à bout de force.
Un soir d'hiver,
après une nouvelle dispute lors
d'une réception officielle au Kremlin,
Nadia rentre dans sa chambre
et se suicide d'une balle de revolver.
La vérité restera
cachée pendant 60 ans.
On raconte aux Russes que Nadia
est morte d'une crise d'appendicite.
Puisque,
pour les dirigeants communistes,
le suicide est une trahison.
Même son amie
Polina Molotov la condamne.
- « Nadia a eu tort.
Elle quitte Staline
à un moment si difficile. »
- Staline n'est pas resté
à l'enterrement.
Il semble anéanti.
- « Nadia !
Nadia, comme nous avions
besoin de toi, moi et les enfants.
Elle m'a abandonné
comme un ennemi.
Elle a fait de moi un infirme.
Elle a brisé ma vie. »
- Staline était brutal,
désormais, il sera impitoyable.
Les premiers visés sont les paysans qui
refusent de céder leurs terres à l'État
et de rejoindre les kolkhozes.
Ces immenses coopératives
où tout est mis en commun
sous contrôle du parti.
Contre eux, Staline envoie des
policiers qui sillonnent la campagne
et réquisitionnent les récoltes.
Ils ont pour mission d'asphyxier
les familles qui résistent à sa politique.
Ils ont tous les droits
et ne reculent devant rien
pour récupérer les provisions
qui ont été cachées.
L'un de ces policiers est Lev Kopelev.
- « J'ai participé à ces expéditions
sondant le sol
pour découvrir les caches.
J'ai vidé des garde-manger en me forçant
à ne pas entendre les pleurs des enfants
et les gémissements des femmes.
Tout était permis.
Détruire,
mentir,
voler.
La fin justifiait les moyens.
Notre but était le triomphe
universel du communisme. »
- 1933,
le résultat.
Les réquisitions de Staline
provoquent une tragédie en Ukraine.
Cette région, l'une des plus riches
d'Europe a déjà été ravagée par la famine
dans les années 20, sous Lénine.
Seulement, cette fois,
l'hécatombe prend
des proportions inimaginables.
Un père écrit à son fils à Moscou.
- « Mon cher fils,
je t'écris pour t'apprendre
que ta mère est morte.
Elle est morte de faim
après des mois de souffrance.
Moi-même,
je n'en ai plus pour longtemps. »
- Certains membres du parti
sur place, n'ont pas compris
que cette famine
n'est connue de Staline.
Ils protestent.
- « Est-ce que le camarade Staline...
Est-ce qu'un membre quelconque du
bureau sait ce qui se passe en Ukraine ?
Sinon,
je vais vous en donner une idée.
Un train chargé de cadavre
vient d'arriver à Kiev.
Après avoir ramassé des corps
pendant tout son trajet. »
- À Moscou, Staline a décidé
d'en finir avec les ukrainiens.
Il interdit aux paysans
affamés de quitter leur village
pour rejoindre les grandes villes.
Il condamne ainsi à la mort
cinq millions de personnes.
C'est l'une des plus grandes
tragédies du siècle...
longtemps resté secrètes.
Au même moment,
le député français
Édouard Herriot débarque en Ukraine,
à l'invitation du gouvernement soviétique.
- « Je fais des vœux ardents
pour la prospérité du peuple russe.
J'espère que mon voyage
sera utile pour son bonheur
et pour la paix des peuples. »
- Le français et la délégation qui
l'accompagne visitent l'Ukraine en train.
Il est ravi du voyage.
- « J'ai traversé l'Ukraine.
Je vous affirme que je l'ai vu
tel un jardin en plein rendement.
Il n'y a que potagers de kolkhozes
irrigués et des récoltes admirables.
Lorsque l'on soutient
que l'Ukraine est dévastée par la famine,
permettez-moi de hausser les épaules. »
- Comment le Français a-t-il pu
passer à côté de millions de morts ?
En fait, les rues ont été
nettoyées avant son arrivée.
Les travailleurs qu'il a
rencontrés étaient des figurants.
On a fait venir de la nourriture.
Edouard-Herriot
s'est fait avoir par la propagande.
À Moscou,
Staline ne gouverne plus
qu'à grands coups de mensonges.
Il a confié une mission
aux journalistes et aux cinéastes.
Ils ne doivent plus
décrire le monde comme il est,
mais comme il devrait être.
La récolte est mauvaise.
On fait filmer des paysans radieux
dans des champs magnifiques.
Les résultats industriels sont décevants,
on publie des chiffres truqués.
On invente même des héros,
comme ce célèbre mineur, Stakhanov.
Lors d'un concours,
il a pulvérisé le record de productivité
en extrayant quatorze fois
plus de charbon que les autres.
Cette histoire est totalement fausse.
Elle a été inventée par le parti.
Elle permet d'abuser les Soviétiques.
En réalité, l'URSS est devenue
un gigantesque État policier.
Les agents de Staline sont partout.
Ils contrôlent toute la société.
Ils ont l'ordre d'arrêter
les suspects et de les déporter.
Partout,
des milliers d'hommes,
de femmes et d'enfants sont regroupés,
puis embarqués
vers des destinations inconnues.
Un enfant se souvient.
- « Combien de jours a duré le voyage ?
Je n'en ai aucune idée.
Dans le wagon,
sept personnes sont mortes de faim.
Quand nous sommes arrivés à Tomsk,
ils nous ont fait sortir
et ils ont déchargé les cadavres.
Des enfants, des jeunes
et les vieux. »
- Ils sont dirigés vers le goulag,
les camps de travail soviétiques.
De véritables camps
de concentration mis en place par Staline,
bien avant leur apparition
dans l'Allemagne de Hitler.
Ces prisonniers sont officiellement
des ennemis de la Révolution.
En réalité,
de simples citoyens, des notables,
des religions qui n'ont rien
à se reprocher, mais n'entrent pas
dans le moule du régime.
Ils sont mélangés au droit commun.
Dans le parti,
on appelle ça, la rééducation
par le travail et on en est fier.
Ici, les esprits déviants
doivent être remis dans le droit chemin.
En fait,
ils sont transformés en esclaves.
Dans les camps du Grand Nord,
la température peut aller à -50 degrés.
Un prisonnier écrit.
- « Il est dangereux de cesser de bouger.
Je n'arrête pas
de me pétrir les orteils
et de serrer les poings.
Le fait de toucher un outil métallique
à mains nues peut vous arracher la peau. »
- Une prisonnière politique,
Maria Yov est à bout de force.
- « Notre équipe
est composée d'intellectuels.
Parmi ces épouvantails,
qui reconnaîtra les violonistes,
les harpistes,
les scientifiques ?
Nous sommes dans un état constant
d'hébétude et d'abrutissement. »
- Le 2 août 1933,
un événement illustre
la cruauté et l'absurdité du système.
Ce jour-là,
on inaugure le canal Staline.
200 kilomètres de voie navigable qui
relie la mer Blanche à la mer Baltique.
Avec de simples pioches,
300 000 prisonniers ont creusé ce canal.
Fait exceptionnel,
Staline a choisi de se déplacer.
Il veut faire du canal qui porte
son nom, le symbole de sa réussite.
En théorie,
c'est un exploit technique.
Le délai de construction
du canal de Panama a été pulvérisé.
En fait, c'est une nouvelle tragédie.
30 000 prisonniers,
soit un sur dix,
sont morts durant le chantier.
Ils sont morts pour rien.
Cela paraît difficile à croire,
mais pour terminer dans les délais,
le canal n'a pas été creusé assez profond.
La plupart des bateaux
ne pourront jamais l'emprunter.
À l'étranger,
on est loin d'imaginer
l'horreur du système stalinien.
La plupart des médias occidentaux,
répercutent les mensonges de la propagande
jusqu'au burlesque.
Alors que partout
se développe le goulag,
voici comment les actualités françaises
décrivent une ancienne prison du tsar,
en Sibérie.
- « Autrefois,
le tsar y enfermait
des révolutionnaires.
À présent, le gouvernement
soviétique a décidé de donner
une autre destination à ce lieu.
On y organisera maintenant
l'élevage en grand des lapins
sous la surveillance
d'un institut scientifique spécial. »
- Chaque année,
intoxiqués par la propagande,
des délégations
communistes du monde entier,
et notamment de France,
viennent saluer à Moscou
le petit père des peuples.
Malgré les crimes de Staline,
les ralliements
de prestige se multiplient,
comme celui de l'écrivain Louis Aragon
qui fait publiquement l'éloge du goulag.
- « Le prolétariat vient
d'entreprendre cette tâche historique,
la rééducation de l'homme par l'homme.
Nous sommes à un moment de l'histoire
de l'humanité qui ressemble au passage
du singe à l'homme. »
- Pour le parti bolchévique
et son chef Staline, hip hip hip.
- Hourra.
- Hip hip hip.
- Comment expliquer
un tel aveuglement ?
Au congrès de 1935,
le discours de Maurice Thorez,
chef du Parti communiste
français, donne l'explication.
Staline a rendu leur fierté
aux ouvriers du monde entier.
- Comprenez camarades,
pendant un moment,
il arrivait que les ouvriers communistes
ne sachent pas comment répondre
dans les usines,
qu'ils ne sachent pas comment
se défendre contre tels reproches
ou telles accusations.
Il était un moment où,
en raison du sectarisme desséchant,
ils n'avaient pas les moyens de répondre.
Il n'y avait plus d'harmonie entre eux
et la grande masse des ouvriers.
Maintenant,
ils sont fiers, ils parlent,
ils répondent,
ils donnent les arguments.
On les considère dans les usines.
On dit,
« Ceux-là sont les communistes.
Ceux-là sont ceux qui organisent
le front uni et le Front populaire. »
Nous sommes sûrs de la victoire,
car la barre de notre navire
est entre les mains fermes
du plus grand des pilotes,
de notre cher et grand Staline."
- Aveuglé par son idéal communiste,
le Français n'a pas vu
ou n'a pas voulu voir
que Staline a déjà tourné la page.
Que son seul but est maintenant
de consolider son pouvoir.
Staline a décidé de liquider toute la
génération qui lui fait encore de l'ombre.
Souvenez-vous,
l'enterrement de Lénine en 1924.
La plupart de ceux qui portaient
le cercueil avec Staline vont mourir.
Kamenev et Zinoviev,
exécutés.
Tomsky, poussé au suicide.
Rykov,
fusillé.
Radek, assassiné.
Il semble éprouver un certain
plaisir à martyriser ses proches.
- « Choisir sa victime,
préparer minutieusement le coup,
assouvir une vengeance implacable
et ensuite, aller se coucher.
Il n'y a rien de plus doux au monde. »
- En 1938, il s'attaque
à son plus proche compagnon de lutte,
son cher Boukharine.
C'est un ami de quinze ans.
Cependant, il a osé
le contredire plusieurs fois.
À ses yeux,
il est devenu un ennemi.
Pour préparer la chute
de cette grande figure du régime,
il lance le rouleau compresseur
de la propagande.
- Dans tout le pays,
on conditionne l'opinion.
- Ces complots sont commis avec férocité
par les agents du capital
par les chiens du fascisme,
Boukharine et sa bande.
- Camarades, ce que j'ai à
vous dire a été confirmé par Staline.
Notre pays est cerné par des ennemis.
Ils veulent détruire
notre patrie et notre peuple.
- Mort à ces ennemis,
mort à ces parasites !
- Pendant ce temps,
à la Loubianka,
le siège de la police secrète,
Boukharine est torturé.
Dans une lettre,
il implore son vieil ami Staline.
- « Je t'écris cette lettre,
qui est sans doute la dernière.
Mon cœur saigne
à la pensée que tu puisses croire
que je suis vraiment coupable.
Je suis prêt à me traîner à genoux
et à t'implorer de m'éviter ce procès.
Si c'est la mort qui m'attend,
je te supplie au nom
de tout ce qui t'est cher,
de ne pas me faire fusiller.
Je veux moi-même
pouvoir absorber du poison.
Je t'en supplie. »
- C'est bien la mort
qui attend Boukharine.
Le 2 mars 1938,
dans une salle remplie
de membres de la police politique,
son procès commence.
C'est une formalité.
- Notre peuple exige une chose,
il faut écraser ces maudites vermines !
- Boukharine est dans le box des accusés,
mais il ne reste
de lui aucune image.
Il n'a pas été jugé assez docile
pour être utilisé par la propagande.
Il est fusillé
et sa famille déportée.
Les purges s'étendent
à toute l'Union soviétique.
Staline voit des ennemis partout.
Il est devenu paranoïaque.
Contre ceux qu'il soupçonne
de menacer son pouvoir,
il encourage la délation.
Dans chaque village,
on doit être prêt à dénoncer
son voisin et même ses propres parents.
Un jeune garçon accuse.
- « Comme pionnier,
je suis obligé de vous le dire.
Mon père a agi de manière
contre-révolutionnaire.
Je vous demande,
non comme fils,
mais comme pionnier de juger sévèrement,
la responsabilité de mon père. »
- Staline dispose d'un homme de main.
Nikolaï Iejov surnommé le Nabot.
C'est le chef de la police secrète.
- « Je suis peut-être court de stature,
mais mes mains sont fortes.
Ce sont les mains de Staline.
Nous lançons une attaque
de grande ampleur contre l'ennemi.
Il y aura des victimes innocentes.
Quand on abat les forêts,
les copeaux volent. »
- Staline lui a fixé
des quotas d'exécutions.
Pour preuve, ce terrible document.
Sur la première ligne,
le nom des républiques
de l'URSS, voici l'Azerbaïdjan.
Puis trois colonnes de chiffres,
une pour les exécutions.
Une autre pour les déportations.
Une dernière pour le total.
Il n'y a aucun nom.
C'est au responsable du parti de trouver
les victimes pour remplir les quotas.
Un dossier pris au hasard dans
les archives de la police politique.
- Nom, Sidorov.
Patrimoine, une maison en bois
de huit mètres sur huit.
Une vache, quatre brebis, deux cochons.
Acte d'accusation,
Sidorov est mal intentionné
envers le pouvoir soviétique.
Il a dit que Staline
a tué un tas de gens,
mais on ne peut pas en parler
sinon on vous met en camp pour 25 ans.
Verdict, fusiller Sidorov
et confisquer tous ses biens.
- On l'appelle la Grande Terreur.
Depuis l'année 1937,
Iejov fait fusiller en moyenne
1000 personnes par jour.
- Frapper, exterminer sans trier.
Mieux vaut aller
trop loin que pas assez.
- En pleine terreur,
la vie continue
comme si de rien n'était.
Au théâtre du Bolchoï à Moscou,
on joue Le Lac des cygnes de Tchaïkovski.
C'est le ballet préféré de Staline.
Il ne rate jamais une représentation.
Chaque soir,
d'après les témoignages,
il regagne le Kremlin pour y signer
les ordres d'exécution qu'on lui prépare.
Il ajoute parfois des commentaires.
- Serrer la vis à ce monsieur.
Battre et battre encore.
Plus les dents sont acérées, mieux c'est.
- La terreur finit par se retourner
contre le chef de la police lui-même.
Iejov est accusé
de trahison, torturé, exécuté
et même effacé des photos officielles.
En 1938, Staline a liquidé tous
ses ennemis réels ou imaginaires.
Il les a peu à peu remplacés
par une nouvelle génération
de militants qui lui doivent tout.
C'est la nomenklatura,
les hommes nouveaux dont rêve
Staline et sur lesquels, il peut compter.
Ils se sont répartis
les biens des victimes de la terreur,
et ils profitent des appartements libérés.
Le 17 mars 1938,
quatre jours après
la fin du procès Boukarine,
nombreux sont ceux qui se rendent
en famille à l'aérodrome de Moscou.
Militants, fonctionnaires,
ils sont tous là pour accueillir un avion
russe qui a relié la Russie à l'Amérique,
en passant par le pôle Nord.
L'accueil du pilote, Tchkalov,
ici au centre, est un événement.
Staline a décidé de faire
de lui un nouveau héros soviétique.
Ce jour-là, dans les rues de Moscou,
Tchkalov crie son amour au guide suprême.
- « Je suis prêt à mourir pour Staline.
S'il faut lui donner nos poumons,
nous donnerons nos poumons à Staline.
S'il faut lui donner notre cœur,
nous lui donnerons notre cœur. »
- Au même moment, en Allemagne.
Le parti nazi est au pouvoir
depuis plus de cinq ans.
Il prône la supériorité
de la race germanique.
À sa tête, le chancelier Adolf Hitler,
a lui aussi établi un régime dictatorial.
Il a déjà annexé l'Autriche.
Il veut s'emparer de tous
ces pays voisins, dont la France.
Il rêve surtout
d'attaquer l'Union Soviétique
et d'annexer son territoire
au profit du peuple allemand.
- « La mission du mouvement nazi
est de détruire le Judéo-bolchevisme.
Détruire la Russie, donnera
au peuple allemand un espace vital
dont la race des maîtres
a besoin pour se nourrir.
Mon ambition est d'être
l'homme qui brisera le marxisme. »
- Staline a tardé à réaliser la menace.
L'U.R.S.S n'est pas prête pour un conflit.
Son armement est dépassé,
son État-Major décimé.
Pendant la terreur, il a fait
fusiller 20 000 officiers soviétiques.
Des membres de l'État-Major
qui figuraient autour de lui
sur ce film de 1934,
il ne reste plus que
quelques généraux dépassés.
Ils ne comprennent
rien à la guerre moderne.
Comme le fringant Boudienny.
- « Vous ne me ferez pas changer d'avis.
Dès que la guerre éclatera,
tout le monde criera,
faites charger la cavalerie. »
- Pour rattraper le retard,
Staline a besoin de temps.
En août 1939,
il parvient à s'entendre avec
Ribbentrop, l'envoyé d'Hitler à Moscou.
Les deux dictatures signent
un pacte de non-agression,
quelques jours seulement
avant le déclenchement de la guerre.
Un accord contre nature,
avec beaucoup d'arrière-pensées,
mais qui donne un répit à Staline.
- « Tout cela n'est qu'un jeu à
qui mettra l'autre dans sa manche.
Vous verrez, la Russie réussira
à éviter la guerre avec l'Allemagne
pendant encore un moment. »
- Huit jours plus tard,
l'Armée allemande attaque la Pologne.
C'est le début de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
En quelques semaines,
les nazis écrasent l'armée polonaise.
La première victoire d'une longue série.
Huit mois plus tard, en mai 1940,
Hitler attaqua l'ouest
et occupe la France en moins de deux mois.
Dans la moitié de l'Europe,
il fait appliquer sa loi.
Occupation militaire,
persécution raciale
et répression politique.
Dans l'intervalle,
Staline ne reste pas inactif.
À la faveur du pacte avec Hitler,
il s'approprie de nouveaux territoires.
À l'hiver 1941,
il se croit encore à l'abri
d'un conflit avec l'Allemagne.
Il se trompe.
C'est le moment où Hitler
décide de réaliser son vieux rêve,
la destruction de l'Union Soviétique.
C'est le plan Barbarossa,
l'une des plus grandes
opérations militaires de l'histoire.
Hitler compte submerger l'armée soviétique
et atteindre Moscou
en quelques semaines seulement.
Dès le printemps,
l'armée allemande se met
en ordre de bataille à la frontière.
Sur place,
des généraux soviétiques
observent les mouvements de troupes.
Ils donnent l'alerte et demandent
l'autorisation de déployer des soldats.
Au Kremlin, Staline, toujours
paranoïaque, redoute un piège.
- « Vous avez une grosse tête,
mais une petite cervelle.
Jamais l'Allemagne ne se lancera
seule dans la guerre contre la Russie. »
- 16 juin 1941,
un espion russe transmet,
« attaque imminente. »
Staline persiste.
- « C'est un désinformateur.
Vous pouvez l'envoyer se faire foutre. »
- 21 juin, veille de l'offensive.
Un déserteur allemand passe la frontière
et prévient que l'attaque
sera lancée à l'aube.
Verdict de Staline,
- « Fusillez-le. »
22 juin 1941,
l'invasion commence.
Trois millions de soldats
allemands attaquent l'U.R.S.S.
Dès les premières heures,
ils détruisent
un millier d'avions au sol.
Le rouleau compresseur
allemand enfonce le front.
Dans un village,
une femme est prise au piège.
- « Des milliers de nos soldats
errent sans but, en désordre.
Nos dirigeants s'en vont.
On nous abandonne à la mort. »
- Le propre fils de Staline,
Yakov, est fait prisonnier
alors qu'il s'enfuit,
déguisé en paysan.
À l'arrière,
la Russie est sous le choc.
La population ne comprend pas
et attend une réaction de Staline.
Cependant, elle ne vient pas.
Les Moscovites, comme le jeune
Guéna essayent d'en savoir plus.
- « On est rivé à la radio,
on attend le discours de Staline.
On a besoin d'entendre sa voix,
mais il reste muet.
C'est Molotov, son adjoint, qui parle.
Tout le monde écoute.
On nous dit que c'est la guerre.
Où est Staline ? »
- Staline est retranché
derrière les murs du Kremlin, anéanti.
- « Tout est perdu.
Lénine avait fondé notre État
et nous, nous avons tout foutu en l'air.
Il nous avait laissé
un héritage fantastique,
et on l'a bousillé. »
- Par ses erreurs répétées,
Staline est responsable du désastre,
mais il ne veut pas l'admettre.
Comme à son habitude,
il cherche des coupables.
Ces milliers de soldats qui se rendent
sont considérés comme des traîtres.
Leurs familles seront déportées.
Contre les déserteurs, il envoie
sur le front des unités spéciales.
Ils sont chargés
de surveiller les soldats.
Il donne des ordres explicites.
En quelques semaines, Staline
multiplie les erreurs de commandement.
En Ukraine, il interdit à
ses généraux d'évacuer la ville de Kiev.
Cinq jours plus tard,
les nazis capturent
500 000 soldats soviétiques.
C'est la plus grosse prise
jamais réalisée par une armée.
En octobre 1941,
quatre mois après le début
de l'offensive Barbarossa,
Staline a presque perdu la guerre.
L'armée allemande n'est plus
qu'à quelques kilomètres de Moscou.
La capitale est
bombardée tous les jours.
La population se réfugie dans le métro.
L'écrivain Viktor Kravchenko
note dans son journal.
- « Moscou donne l'impression d'agoniser.
La panique règne
et il circule les bruits
les plus incroyables.
Certains disent qu'un coup
d'État a éclaté au Kremlin
et qu'on a arrêté Staline. »
- En fait, Staline s'est lui
aussi réfugié dans le métro.
C'est ici,
alors que tous ses fidèles pris de
panique, le pressent d'évacuer la capitale
qu'il prend une décision
qui va tout changer.
Malgré le danger,
il décide de rester à Moscou.
Dans quelques heures,
il s'adressera à ses soldats.
7 novembre, 8 heure du matin,
des régiments rejoignent la place
rouge en pleine tempête de neige,
à l'appel de Staline.
Les chars viennent
directement du front et sont armés.
Les Allemands peuvent
attaquer à tout moment,
mais le discours de Staline
galvanise les soldats.
- « Partisans, partisanes,
le monde entier nous regarde
et attend que nous anéantissions.
Les hordes de pillards
et d'envahisseurs allemands.
Mort à l'occupation allemande.
Gloire à notre patrie,
à la liberté, à l'indépendance.
En venant vers la victoire
sous le drapeau de Lénine. »
- En quelques jours,
l'armée Soviétique parvient
à stabiliser le front devant Moscou.
Ce n'est que 10 mois
plus tard, à l'été 1942,
que va se jouer la plus
grande bataille du siècle.
Nous sommes à Stalingrad.
C'est le tournant
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Les Allemands, qui n'ont pas
réussi à faire tomber Moscou, veulent
conquérir ce point de passage
vers le pétrole de la mer Caspienne.
Ils occupent 90 % de la ville.
Il leur reste encore quelques
centaines de mètres à gagner.
Les Soviétiques leur opposent
une résistance acharnée.
Parmi eux, se trouve le soldat Koseaïnov.
- « On entend les pas
et le souffle des soldats allemands.
Je ne peux pas
les voir à cause de la fumée.
On tire au juger, à l'oreille.
Ma tête bourdonne. »
- Au total, deux millions d'hommes
vont mourir à Stalingrad.
Pour la première fois
depuis le début de la guerre,
Staline a décidé de ne pas intervenir
et de laisser faire son chef d'État-Major,
le général Joukov.
Joukov veut prendre au piège
des Allemands dans la ville
qu'ils viennent de conquérir.
19 novembre 1942,
7 heures du matin,
1400 chars, plus de 1000 avions
et 1 000 000 de soldats soviétiques
se ruent sur les flancs de l'armée nazie.
Ces images filmées après la bataille
lors d'une reconstitution, montrent
la jonction des deux armées russes.
Quelques semaines plus tard,
300 000 soldats allemands encerclés,
mal équipés et affamés,
finissent par se rendre avec leur chef,
le maréchal von Paulus.
C'est la première fois
qu'un maréchal nazi est capturé vivant.
Pour Staline, c'est un miracle.
Grâce au sacrifice de ces soldats,
c'est lui qui le premier aux yeux
du monde, a fait plier Adolf Hitler.
C'est lui qui lance
la contre-offensive héroïque
des soldats russes contre l'Allemagne.
Malgré ses crimes,
malgré son pacte en 1939 avec Hitler,
Staline est devenu incontournable.
À Moscou,
lors de la visite du général de Gaulle,
puis quelques mois
plus tard à la conférence de Yalta,
les Alliés viennent tous
rencontrer le grand Staline.
Le Britannique Churchill porte un toast.
- « La vie de Staline est
ce qu'il y a de plus précieux
pour chacun d'entre nous.
J'espère sincèrement que le peuple
de l'Union soviétique pourra conserver
longtemps son maréchal. »
- Churchill sait que
depuis la victoire de Stalingrad,
l'U.R.S.S est en train
de devenir une superpuissance.
Qu'après des mois de contre-offensive,
l'Armée rouge va bientôt entrer à Berlin.
Printemps 1945,
ces armes terrifiantes,
les orgues de Staline
pilonnent la capitale allemande.
Staline a décidé de venger
Stalingrad et de détruire Berlin.
Devant une telle puissance de feu,
l'Allemagne finit
par capituler le 8 mai 1945.
Deux mois plus tard,
le généralissime Staline
arrive dans la capitale allemande
pour célébrer sa victoire.
Dans ce célèbre film de propagande,
on accueille le vainqueur
de Hitler comme un messie.
En fait, c'est une fiction
où Staline est joué par un sosie.
Cette arrivée magistrale
n'a jamais eu lieu.
Staline a peur de l'avion
et contrairement à ces images,
il déteste la foule.
- Camarades,
aujourd'hui, nous célébrons
la grande victoire
sur l'Allemagne fasciste.
Le vrai Staline s'est
rendu en train blindé à Potsdam,
dans la banlieue de Berlin,
où 5 000 policiers sont
mobilisés pour son arrivée.
Il est obsédé par les attentats.
S'il a accepté de sortir de son pays
pour la première fois en 30 ans,
c'est que l'occasion en vaut la peine.
Il a rendez-vous autour
de la table de négociations,
avec ses alliés américains
et britanniques.
Depuis la conférence de Yalta,
il exige purement
et simplement la moitié de l'Europe.
C'est-à-dire tous les pays
que son armée a libérés pendant la guerre.
L'exigence de Staline
est acceptée par les Alliés.
La domination soviétique
de l'Europe de l'Est peut commencer.
Elle va durer près d'un demi-siècle.
Pour les Russes, le prix
de la victoire est exorbitant.
Le conflit a anéanti 70 000 villages
et tué 26 millions de personnes.
A l'été 1945,
les soldats commencent
à rentrer dans leurs foyers
et s'apprêtent à retrouver leur famille.
Un soldat raconte.
- « Les gens hurlent, ils courent,
ils pleurent à l'arrivée du train.
Les hommes embrassent leur femme.
Ils prennent dans leurs bras
les enfants qu'ils n'ont pas vu grandir.
Ils montrent fièrement
leurs décorations et leurs blessures. »
- Après tant de souffrances,
tous aspirent à la tranquillité.
Pour eux, les crimes de Staline
ne sont plus que de vieux souvenirs.
À Moscou, Staline
est au sommet de sa puissance.
Cela fait plus de 20 ans
qu'il dirige l'Union soviétique.
Pour la victoire, on lui a
préparé un spectacle grandiose.
Avec des milliers de figurants.
Le général américain
Eisenhower a fait le déplacement.
Pourtant Staline a l'air absent.
Sa santé est fragile.
Il a des trous de mémoire.
Il a fait plusieurs attaques cardiaques.
Surtout, c'est un homme seul.
Pendant la guerre,
il a perdu son fils Yakov,
prisonnier des Allemands.
On raconte que Yakov a cherché
à s'échapper en franchissant les barbelés.
Staline avait refusé de l'échanger
contre le maréchal von Paulus,
comme le proposait Hitler.
- « Si j'avais échangé Yakov,
qu'auraient dit
les pères de famille du parti
dont les enfants
étaient eux aussi prisonniers ?
Si j'avais fait ça,
j'aurais cessé d'être Staline. »
- Sa vie privée est un désastre.
Il ne voit presque plus
son deuxième fils, l'aviateur Vassili.
Celui-ci devenu alcoolique
et continue pourtant
de survoler la place Rouge
aux commandes de son avion.
Plus paranoïaque que jamais,
Staline s'est même fâché avec Svetlana,
sa fille chérie devenue une jeune femme.
Il ne comprend pas
son besoin de s'amuser.
Il n'accepte pas
ses aventures sentimentales,
celles notamment avec
le réalisateur juif, Alexeï Kapler,
qu'il a envoyé au goulag.
Il n'accepte pas non plus son mariage
avec Gregory Morozov, juif lui aussi.
Le vainqueur de Hitler
semble devenu antisémite.
- Toute la génération précédente
a été contaminée par le sionisme.
- Maintenant, ils sont en train
d'en régimenter la jeunesse.
- Dès la fin de la guerre, Staline
a relancé les purges au gré de sa folie.
Avec deux millions de prisonniers,
dont un grand nombre de Juifs,
jamais le goulag n'a été aussi rempli.
En France,
les communistes qui se sont battus
contre les nazis pendant la guerre,
ils continuent de vénérer Staline.
En 1949, il fête son 70ᵉ anniversaire.
De partout, on envoie
des cadeaux au Kremlin.
Comme le raconte le poète Paul Éluard.
- « Dans ce petit atelier de Belleville,
les ouvriers ont passé 300 heures
à fabriquer avec application
un cadeau pour installer.
Leur cadeau, un tour miniature. »
- Les crimes de Staline
continuent d'être passés sous silence.
- « Nous n'avons pas oublié ce
qu'on a subi pendant l'occupation nazie.
Il faut comprendre
qu'un de nos camarades a été interné.
Le fils d'un autre est
tombé dans la lutte clandestine.
La femme et la fille
de notre directeur ont été déportées.
Sans la victoire de Stalingrad,
notre village, Grigny,
serait toujours occupé par les nazis,
comme toute la France,
comme toute l'Europe.
Aussi, nous tous, paysans de Grigny,
nous souhaitons bon anniversaire
et longue vie au généralissime Staline
qui nous a libéré par sa victoire. »
- « Nous souhaitons longue vie au guide
clairvoyant de la classe ouvrière
à Staline,
l'homme de la paix. »
- Pour son anniversaire,
l'homme de la paix a convoqué à
Moscou le gratin communiste international.
Notamment le Chinois Mao Tsé toung.
Cependant, c'est une petite fille
de 12 ans qui tient la vedette.
Elle s'appelle Natalia.
C'est la fille de Poskrebychev,
le secrétaire de Staline.
Elle a obtenu l'honneur
de lire un poème au guide suprême.
- Vivez près de nous très cher.
Conduisez nous par vos lumières
pour que le régime soviétique s'épanouisse
et se renforce chaque jour.
- La salle applaudit à
tout rompre cette scène touchante,
mais la petite fille
ignore un détail cruel.
Quelques années plus tôt,
Staline a fait fusiller sa mère.
À 70 ans, le petit père des peuples
se sent plus que jamais indispensable.
- « Que feriez-vous sans moi ?
Vous êtes aveugles, des petits chats.
Vous ne voyez pas l'ennemi.
Le pays mourra, parce que vous
ne savez pas reconnaître l'ennemi. »
4 mars 1953.
Cette fois,
c'est Staline qui vient de mourir.
Aucun détail dans les journaux.
On ne le saura que plus tard.
Staline a agonisé seul
dans sa chambre pendant deux jours,
sans personne pour le secourir.
Pas même ses médecins,
terrorisés à l'idée de prendre
une mauvaise décision et d'être fusillé.
Sa dépouille est exposée
dans la salle des Colonnes,
là où il avait fait condamner
ses amis lors des procès de Moscou.
Chez les membres du parti,
l'émotion est réelle.
Une institutrice a du mal
à imaginer la vie sans Staline.
- Qu'est-ce qui va se passer maintenant ?
Comment va-t-on vivre ?
Qu'est-ce qui va arriver au pays ?
Sur la place Rouge,
les officiels récitent leur discours.
- Notre maitre et guide,
le plus grand génie de toute
l'humanité a terminé son chemin glorieux.
- Pourtant, malgré
les consignes de deuil,
loin des caméras,
des milliers de victimes de Staline
commencent secrètement à se réjouir.
Au camp de Vorkouta,
à l'extrême nord de la Russie,
les déportés se sont mis
à genoux en entendant la nouvelle.
- « Que le diable emporte son âme.
Grâce à Dieu, aujourd'hui,
l'homme à la moustache
est parti en enfer. »
- Durant son règne,
l'homme qui avait
promis le paradis sur terre,
il a provoqué la mort
de 20 millions de personnes.